Welcome to AERA English TV's Native Maestro.
I'm your maitre d', Seita.
And this program is designed to help you become the native maestro.
Now, today's Maestro Hook.
Now remember, a Hook is a good conversation piece that you can use with a foreigner...
...when you don't have anything good to talk about...
...or you need a good conversation piece.
So today's Hook is...
...where to take a foreigner...
...when you're the tour guide and they wanna see the real Japan,...
...the real Tokyo more like.
Well, I think the best way to do it is to show them like...
...the grand metropolis of Japan, like the buildings and like the big city areas.
And also show them the very traditional side of Japan like...
...gardens and cherry blossoms, and temples and shrines.
So that two big dichotomy is what makes Japan really, really eccentric.
Alright, so.
Some view.
Some place.
Some guy.
Wow! That restaurant is a great place.
It's some dinner.
Great!
It's quite amazing!
I hear it's quite amazing.
Alright. So, Maestro Lines.
Yeah, there's a lot of great cherry blossoms in Japan...
...and when it's the season, it blooms.
It's some view.
The city view from a big building is great.
It's some scenery.
Or, that restaurant is quite amazing.
You gotta go visit.
Or, in April, it's the best time to come to Japan and you can see cherry blossoms...
...and you can see a great scenery.
It's quite amazing.
Alright. That's it for today and hope you liked it.
And next week there'll be more contents to help you become the native maestro.
See you later!